الى ايران حيث كشفت وزاره الدفاع عن صاروخ
باليستين جديد يحمل اسم خيبر وهو نسخه
معدله من الصاروخ خرم شهر وصنفته بالجيل
الرابع من هذا الطراز ويبلغ مدى الصاروخ
الفيل متر ويحمل راسا حربيا يبلغ وزنه الف
وخمسمائه
اوضحت الوزاره بان الصاروخ يصعب استهدافه
من قبل انظمه الدفاع الجوي بسبب سرعته
الفائقه
للمتابعه معنا من طهران مراسل الجزيره نور
الدين الدغير اذا نور الدين بدايه السياق
الذي ياتي فيه اعلان هذه الخطوه من طهران
واهميه هذا الصاروخ بالنسبه لها
نعم سهام السياق يبدو مهما كذلك في
الاعلان اليوم عن هذا الصاروخ في ظل
التهديدات الاسرائيليه القادمه من تل ابيب
باتجاه طهران وباتجاه استهداف المواقع
النوويه ربما قد يكون الامر عاديا خاصه
اذا ما علمنا ان ايران ما بين الفينه
والاخرى تعلن عن تطوير منظومات صاروخيه
تختبر الصواريخ لكن ان يكون هذا الاعلان
في هذا الوقت بالذات فهو يحمل بالطبيعه
الرسائل العسكريه وهنا نتلمس الموقف
الايراني من هذه التجربه الصاروخيه حينما
يتحدث وزير الدفاع الايراني حين ويقول بان
رساله هذا الاختبار هي موجهه للاعداء بحسب
تعبيره وان ايران لن تتهاون في الدفاع عن
امنها وعن مكتسباتها الثوريه وبالتالي
يمكن القول بان الكشف عن هذا الصاروخ قد
يبدو كذلك الرساله مهمه في وقتها باتجاه
من تسميهم الاعداء والان يبدو ان الصوره
واضحه بالنسبه الايرانيه وهي التهديدات
الاسرائيليه خاصه اذا ما اخذنا
بطبيعه الصاروخ الذي يبلغ مداه الفيل
كيلومتر واذا ما اخذنا بالابعاد التقنيه
لهذا الصاروخ فيمكن ان يستهدف اسرائيل
بحسب ما يقول الايرانيون هنا خاصه حتى من
اقصى نقطه بالشرق الايراني باعتبار ان
2000 كيلومتر وبالتالي السياق الجديد
السياق التهديدات سياق التهديدات
والتهديدات المنظمه بين طهران يعطي لهذا
الصاروخ ولهذا الاختبار في هذا الوقت
بالذات اهميه على ان ايران مستعده لكافه
الاختبار للخيارات وخاصه الخيارات
الدفاعيه لمواجهه اي هجوم او استهداف اي
مواقع حساسه ومهمه لدى ايران خاصه حينما
نتحدث عن المواقع النوويه التي تبدو انها
موضوع على قائمه الاستهدافات كما يتحدث
الاسرائيليون من طهران ومن تل ابيب وكذلك
المواقع العسكريه الايرانيه لكن كذلك سهام
هنا لابد ان نقف عند نقطه مهمه لدى
الايرانيين يمكن ان نضعها في السياق
السياسي والسياق التقني حينما ت اليوم
لتعلن عن تطوير نسخه جديده من صاروخ خرم
شهر اربعه واطلقت عليه خيبر هذا الصاروخ
الذي تحدث على ان مداه 2000 كيلومتر وعلى
ان راسه الحربي يبلغ وزنه تقريبا حوالي
1500 كيلوغرام وانه قادر على الفرار من
المضادات الدفاعيه قد تكون النقطه التي
يتحدث عنها كذلك وزير الدفاع الايراني
حينما يقول بان ايران ستواصل تزويد قواتها
المسلحه بالصواريخ وبالمسيرات وبطبيعه
الرادارات المختلفه هنا نقطه اساسيه ربما
تشكل احدى نقاط الاشتباك ما بين ايران وما
بين الولايات المتحده الامريكيه واسرائيل
والمجموعه الغربيه وهي مفهوم الصواريخ
البلسيه التي طالما تحدث الغرب عن ضروره
ادراجها ضمن مفاوضات ايرانيه غربيه من اجل
الحد من هذه القدرات الصاروخيه اذا ان
تعلن كذلك ايران عن هذا النموذج من
الصواريخ بهذه الخصائص هنا رساله واضحه
كما يقول المسؤولون الايرانيون على انهم
لن يتخلوا عن ترسنتهم الصاروخيه وانها غير
قابله للتفاوض وبانها تشكل جزء مهم من
عمليه الرد على العسكري وضمن السياسات
والاستراتيجيات العسكريه الايرانيه في
مواجهه اي تهديدات شكرا لك نور الدين
التغيير المراسل الجزيره كنت معنا من
طهران